i understand that the two of you have a
yoga practice that you
you know do every day or that you were a
former yoga teacher i taught yoga for
many years yes okay
what principles from the practice from
that mindset do you apply to the
entertainment business your films your
screenwriting to producing to actually
yeah well i mean
obviously the the practice of ashtanga
yoga is really a physical it's a very
physical practice and it gets you
exerted to the point where
it requires you to quiet your mind
because it is such a physical
practice and then when you
finally finish it you get into a place
of
self-reflection contemplation and quiet
in your mind so you basically
you basically tap into
another area of your mind that you don't
normally access
in your daily life and within
working within the the film industry you
know that's something that's not
required of you to do because
there could be you know a lot of
cynicism around it as a you know it's
not really an art form or it's you know
it's so superfluous that you know people
don't really care or it's something
that's in the theater this week and gone
next week and you know there'll be
another dozen of them out you know the
year after or whatever but
it does allow you to
be able to view and
see things differently
in as
in a in as much as
you're you have a
pure intention for what you're trying to
do i mean diane's thing was always when
we
started obsolete was look hey whoever
gets on board with this
we it may never go anywhere
but we'll make a bunch of new friends
and we'll get better at what we do that
was exactly the intention from the very
get-go and that comes out of
the whole idea of
just being open in a yoga practice and i
think it's also that thing of
non-attachment to outcome because i
think that's one of the biggest things
in yoga practices
you know uh it's being focused just
being in the moment and being present to
what's happening without you know
without having a goal without um
doing it for something it's like we say
you wash the dishes to wash the dishes
you don't wash them to get clean dishes
you know and i think
in filmmaking i really feel something
definitely i know that guides me is just
that thing you don't control the outcome
of uh you know making a film you know
what you do control is how you are in
each moment as you make it and i sort of
think like as you're going through the
process if you just work in a way that's
you know open-hearted and it's inclusive
and that's positive then no matter what
happens you've
you have a great experience and things
are good you know and you really don't
control what happens to your film
afterwards so like i i mean i feel like
i'm definitely guided by that i mean
there's so many there's to be honest
because yoga is like such i mean uh
such an underpinning of my life
so i feel like it underpins everything
like also in the content and the kinds
of films like i feel there's a sort of
responsibility in the material that you
create as well you know the
the films that you make anything that
you put out in the world has an effect
on other people
and i think it's really important to be
conscious about that you know what what
energy are you putting out through your
work you know
so there's many there's so there's so
many different aspects i think the
number one thing though really is that
um that thing about the
the outcome you know not to be attached
and yoga teaches you that in a very
profound way you know that really just
be in the moment be focused on the
process and let go of expectations and
uh and what's going to happen with it at
the end because that you never control
and i think if you do just stay in that
you just have a better chance of making
a better film
so that day when you went to the
sundance office
it seems like you almost it was like
okay let's just give it a shot but was
there both inside of you this part where
you know it's not going to happen and
we're just feeling we're going we're
doing i'm just i'm sorry because it's
not cheap to you know i mean it's a
great festival but it's yeah i went in
there and i
i felt really confident
because i i'm
pretty much a confident
person anyway but i felt really
confident
in the experience that we'd had
and what we'd achieved with what we'd
done with obsolete
that i was really confident that
if this
hallowed ground is not the place for
this there is another hallowed ground
for this
project
and it's somewhere else but i felt
confident in as much as
there's only been
two
experiences that i've had in
a 20-year span of being in the film
industry where i really felt
like
this is really an amazing experience the
other experiences that i've had in the
film industry were just work-related
right they were just
jobs and means to an end and some of
them were good and well-intentioned but
they fell
way short
of
the experience that i had with obsolidia
and
the other experience that i had was
working on titanic where
there are two extremities one is a micro
micro budget film and the other one was
one of the most expensive films of its
time
and
on both of those experiences
the the leader at the helm
diane or james cameron
both had the same passion and the same
enthusiasm for what they were doing and
that
filtered down to
the
the likes of me you know that filtered
all the way down and that passion
is so palpable that every day no matter
how tired you are when you show up at
that set that heightened imagination
creation that you're making you just
aren't you're just infused with it you
have to be a part of it you can't
it it's undeniable
and those were the two experiences where
i went this is really amazing so i knew
handing off
obsolidia
that it was coming from that place
and i was confident that if this wasn't
the hallowed ground that it would be
accepted at there was another hallowed
ground that it would be accepted
and that it would find its audience
eventually and i still think that the
potential for its audience hasn't even
been reached yet i think it as a film
and as a story and as a as a
philosophy
will probably be
more received or more
better received
further down the line
as things do come to a change and as
things do
progress in the way that the
philosophical ideas in the film
actually
come to bear
and
that's
where i feel
you know
the two experiences
micro budget and multi
multi-million dollar budget but yet the
same
infusion of passion
you know i mean
diane bell and james cameron
in the same sentence
you know i mean it's pretty it's pretty
amazing you know but are you
experiencing there was one thing i will
say um uh just picking up on that like
there was definitely like when we were
making the film it just was it was a
great experience and it was just that
feeling of everyone coming together and
just something really
uh really great happening that is that
is true i didn't i still didn't think
that we were getting sundance or didn't
have that as a sort of i mean i'd always
hoped for it because i always you know
admired sundance and thought that would
be amazing but i did not expect it but i
had no doubts about it i had no doubts
about the film at all ever like when it
got independent spirited awards i went
yeah that makes sense
you know yeah sure
makes sense it's it's done with pure
passion and love and you know it's
creative and it's artistic and yeah
makes sense didn't didn't question it in
the slightest you know and that wasn't
arrogance that was just like well i feel
really
confident in this loaf of bread i just
baked you know it's really good it
tastes great
try some you know
that was it